for many americans the holiday shopping  season is well underway  a recent survey from a firm found nearly  half started buying gifts online in  september  but the shift to the web and the  pandemic are having a big impact on  local retailers  the survey found nearly half of  respondents plan to do their holiday  shopping online  kim perkins with the research firm  retail metrics says online holiday  shoppers  should start now you're looking at a  potential doubling in the number of  e-commerce orders this year  i think this year if consumers wait to  the last minute they're going to be  deeply disappointed  experts say the spending forecast for  this season could go either way  with unemployment and stimulus  uncertainty people may not spend as much  or they may spend more  since they aren't traveling and they may  be looking for some retail therapy